bonsoir nicolas klain merci d'être avec
nous pedro sanchez qui a donc présenté
un ce remaniement pour préparer la
relance économique officiellement c'est
le principal défi du gouvernement
aujourd'hui
alors c'est un des défis du gouvernement
bien évidemment puisque les différentes
mesures qui ont été prises au cours de
l'année 2020 et même au début de l'année
2002 21 dans le cadre de la pandémie
coronavirus comme confinement général de
mars à début juin
fin mai début juin 2020 ont eu des
conséquences très nette et très néfastes
sur l'économie espagnole donc c'est un
des défis
un autre défi ça va être de poursuivre
la campagne de vaccination toujours
contre la copie 19 campagne de
vaccination qui est très avancé en
espagne plus qu'en france c'est pour ça
que quand la france donne des leçons sur
la situation sanitaire à l'espagne on
peut sourire disons et puis il va y
avoir également d'autres problématiques
auxquelles devra s'atteler ce nouveau
gouvernement ce gouvernement remanié
la problématique territoriale avec la
catalogne mais pas seulement une
problématique beaucoup plus large
les thématiques de société par exemple
la place des femmes aux également
plusieurs polémiques récentes et des
faits divers tragiques autour de
l'homophobie en espagne enfin voilà
différentes différents défis qui ne sont
pas des moindres pour ce nouveau
gouvernement ce remaniement du
gouvernement c'était inévitable
également pour préparer les prochaines
élections législatives et régionales 2
2023 alors cela semblait effectivement
inévitable la rumeur courait depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines pour plusieurs mois
c'est le choix de la date qui est un
petit peu surprenant parce qu'on est
quand même au début des vacances d'été
peut-être que ce remaniement aurait été
plus attendus à la rentrée en septembre
il est vrai que le gouvernement de pedro
sanchez le parti socialiste et ses
alliés de nida se poser moss sont en
mauvaise posture dans les nombreux
sondages d'opinion y compris au niveau
national qui sont sortis depuis les
élections régionales mme adrienne du 4
mai dernier comme le rappelait votre
sujet ça a été une déconvenue pour la
gauche très largement et en particulier
pour les socialistes
et il est vrai que pedrosa en chef
espère avec ce gouvernement donner un
nouveau souffle à la législature qui a
fait suite aux élections de novembre
2019 et donc en vue des élections
régionales et municipales du premier
semestre 2023 probablement aux alentours
d'avril mai et des élections générales
qui pour le moment sont prévues au
dernier trimestre de l'année 2000 23
probablement novembre ou décembre
63 % de femmes plus jeunes ce
gouvernement également le nouveau la
nouvelle équipe de pedro sanchez se veut
aussi un moyen de séduire la jeunesse
alors c'est évidemment ce qui est
affiché parce qu'en réalité la jeunesse
espagnole on le voit à travers non
seulement les enquêtes d'opinion mais
aussi les élections qui ont lieu depuis
à peu près un an un an et demi la
jeunesse se détournent du gouvernement
de coalition non seulement des
socialistes mais aussi de la gauche
radicale entre guillemets dont dix à se
poser moss qui pourtant avait fait de la
jeunesse
un de ses principaux thèmes de campagne
un de ses principaux thèmes politiques
et la jeunesse représentés pour cette
frange de la politique espagnole de
l'arc parlementaire une force
or on voit que la jeunesse se détournent
de ces forces là notamment au profil de
la droite en partie le parti populaire
la droite on va dire classique mais
aussi la droite radicale ou extrême
droite de vox
qui séduit assez intensément la jeunesse
en tout cas plus que ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer
donc évidemment la jeunesse c'est un
comment on peut l'expliquer tout d'abord
parce que les attentes et les défis
auxquels doit faire face la jeunesse en
espagne le chômage les problèmes
d'émancipation l'accès au logement le
problème de la maternité et de la
paternité
tous ces problèmes là pour le moment
n'ont pas été résolus par la gauche et
il semblerait que la gauche apparaissent
aujourd'hui relativement peu crédible on
verra si ça change mais en tout cas
relativement peu crédible pour les
résoudre et par ailleurs la jeunesse
espagnole a été séduite en tout cas pour
une partie d'entre elles bien sûr par un
certain nombre de thématiques et d'
approche de la droite de la droite
radicale espagnol sur les questions de
liberté économique individuel
donc je crois que là est véritablement
on voit des changements sociologiques se
produire on verra s'il se poursuivre ou
pas il ya eu également un parmi les
événements de ces dernières semaines la
grâce des leaders catalans est-ce
qu'elle a fragilisé le parti de ce pedro
sanchez c'est une décision qui a été
jugées impopulaires par les espagnols
alors là aussi toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion dont on dispose montrent
qu'une majorité des espagnols fume des
sondés favorables à cette grâce je me
permets juste ici d'apporter un
correctif amical à votre journaliste qui
a parlé de prisonniers politiques
catalans ça c'est ce que proclament les
anciens prisonniers ancien responsable
séparatistes catalans ils nous ont
reconnus comme tels par personne ce sont
des hommes politiques en prison ce qui
n'est pas la même chose
donc effectivement cette décision de
grâce a été très mal prise par une
majorité d'espagnols y compris parmi les
électeurs du parti socialiste il faut
comprendre qu'en plus cette décision de
grâce n'avait absolument pas été
annoncée par pedro cents us
lors des différentes campagnes
législatives des deux campagnes
législatives de 2010 9 et qu'au
contraire ils avaient
réaffirmé à plusieurs reprises que qu'il
souhaitait que ses dirigeants
emprisonnés fassent leur peine de prison
jusqu'au bout en réalité c'est
simplement un geste qu'il attendait de
faire pour se concilier des partis
séparatistes au parlement national
espagnol afin de pouvoir terminer la
présente législature puisque le
gouvernement s'attachait 7 en minorité
au parlement pour leur a pris merci
nicolas klain je rappelle d'engager un
spécialiste un d'espagne contemporain
auteur de comprendre l'espagne
d'aujourd'hui manuel de civilisation aux
éditions ellipses hommes